اهلا من جديد اهلا ماسك قلب الدنيا من كم
شهر بخدمه تويتر بلو اللي هي الخدمه
المدفوعه من تويتر مقابل 8 دولارات بتعطي
ميزات اضافيه للمشترك فيها وفي هذه الخدمه
يعني تحديدا وابرزها التوثيق يعني اي احد
حسابه موثق هو يبغى يفضل موثق لازم يدفع
اليوم
غار من ماسك فقامت متى اعلنت انه هي كمان
بتختبر خدمه اشتراك جديده بفلوس اسمها متى
وهذه على فيسبوك وانستجرام ومقابل 11
دولار وتسعه وتسعين سنت على الموقع و14
دولار وتسعه وتسعين سنت على اجهزه ابل
واندرويد وبتقول متى بعنوانها ان الخدمه
هدفها انه صناع المحتوى يتعزز وجودهم
وبتستعرض لائحه من المميزات اللي بيحصل
عليها المشترك واللي ابرزها التوثيق ومنها
كمان انه في حاله الحاجه لمساعده حيكون في
تواصل فوري مع بني ادم لان العادي انه
صاروا انه الواحد ترد لا هذا اذا لاقيها
طبعا اصلا او اذا ردت عليه يعني اصلا طب
انا الان هذا قلب الدنيا والكل جالس بيقول
ايش فيه خلاص كده التوثيق صار متاح لاي
شخص بيدفع فلوس وانه كده يعني عادي هيفقد
قيمته يعني التوثيق هذا غير كمان في ناس
شايفه انه في ناس مو محتاجه تدفع مشاهير
ومعروفين لازم حساباتهم اصلا تكون موثقه
وانه ما ينفع اي شخص يدفع يتوثق حسابه بعد
تويتر بلوه ومتى
صار شبه متاح للجميع احنا سالناكم على
حساباتنا لو انتم شايفين انه التوثيق بدا
يفقد قيمته لما صار بمقابل مادي واجاباتكم
جاءت كالتالي 73% اجابوا انه نعم ايه بدا
يفقد قيمته و 23% شافوا انه لا ما فقد
قيمته عادي
طيب احنا معنا في الاستوديو المختص في
التقنيه كريم فريد اهلا فيك معنا يا كريم
يعني الواحد لما يشوف هذا الشيء اول شيء
لما نعملها ايلون ماسك قلنا
مبلغ كبير وعنده مشاكل ماليه وبده يحل
ازماك طبيعي لكن لما تيجي متى وتعملها
اللي هم ارباح بالهبل اعلانات بالهبل كله
بالهبل ايش بيفكروا من ورا الموضوع اولا
متى عندهم مشكله كبيره زي بالظبط من في
الربع الاخير من عشرين واحد وعشرين متى
كان اجمالي دخلها حوالي 33 مليار دولار
وكان ارباحهم من التلاته وتلاتين مليار
دولار تقريبا 30% ولكن في الربع الاخير من
22 هامش ربحهم نزل تقريبا 14% فعندهم ازمه
كبيره التكلفه اعلى والدخل من الاعلانات
وغيرها كبير جدا مش كبير جدا يغطي التكلفه
ويحافظ على مستوى الربح اللي كانوا
متعودين عليها
بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي المعلنين المشاكل
والازمات اللي مرت بها متى الخصوصيه العام
الركود العام حل الاقتصاديه وهكذا لانه
حتى هم كمان برضو خفضوا من عدد موظفينهم
يعني طيب الان لما يعملوا خطوه زي هذه بعد
ماسك سوى هذه الخطوه هل هو اقرار منهم
بانه اللي ماشي عليه الم صح ولا انه فكره
طلعت من عنده وقالوا اوكي حلوه زي ما
فيسبوك وميتها عملوا مع كل حاجه تقريبا
شافوا غيرهم بيعملوها تجليد نوعا ما
بيحاولوا ان هم يقتبسوها او اعتقد ان
المصطلح كويس
لما اخذوا الستوريز من السناب بالضبط فهنا
هم اخذوا الفكره ولكن الفكره في النهايه
هي مدخل كويس وكان من الضروري في مرحله من
المراحل ان نظام الاشتراكات يدخل عالم
المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لان لازم يحصل
نقله ان اعلانات مش كل الناس عايزه تشوف
اعلانات وحجم الاعلانات اصبح مزعج بشكل
كبير فكان لازم يحصل ان يكون في مصدر تاني
للدخل للشركات وفي نفس الوقت
السابسكريبشنز ديت او الاشتراكات تتيح
للمستخدمين بعض المميزات بيستخدم
ودلوقتي بعده يستخدمه التوثيق حاله من ان
هم تاني موقع تواصل مبنيه على جذب
الانتباه
ادفعوا مقابل الواجهه الاجتماعيه وفي
المقابل تدريجيا يتم تقديم خدمات اكبر
اجتماعيه هذه لما انت تصير تتوزع على اي
احد هيدفع 11 دولار او ثمانيه دولار بطلت
توجعها اجتماعيه اصبحت واقعه وهنا هيوصل
هيوصلنا لنقله تانيه واعتقد ان هنا نقله
صحيه نوعا ما ان مع الوقت لو استمر
الموضوع بالشكل ده وبقى فيه اهتمام كبير
به وزي ما احنا شايفين من تويتر كل الناس
تقريبا بقوم بالضبط ولكن مع اعتقد ان دوت
هيسمح ان على الاقل عدد الحسابات الوهميه
ممكن يبتدي يقل وهنا يكون صحي اكتر على
المدى الطويل اوكي هذه نقطه مهمه مره
واعتقد انه في طرق كثيره اصلا لما بنفتح
الحساب والكلام هذا كله يمكن التعامل فيها
والتحقق من الحساب مو وهمي بس انه لما
نعطي اشاره الفيري فايد هذه لكل احد هنا
صار عندك مشكله طب يعني ايش الفرق بين
الشخص اللي بيدفع وبين يعني مثلا
هلدفعوا مثلا هل مثلا يعني حسابات رؤساء
الدول وكذا حيدفعوا هم اكيد بيقدروا
يدفعوا ولكن هنا الفرق هيكون مختلف ان زي
ما له ماسك عمل تيج مختلفه عمل كذا شكل
للفيرفيكيشن فعمل الحسابات البيزنس والناس
المعلنين عمل لهم شكل مختلف وعلامه
ذهبيه عشان يحسسهم ان هم مختلفين عمل
الحسابات الحكوميه ورؤساء الدول وهكذا
علامه رماديه والناس العاديه اللي هم عمه
الناس عمل لهم العلامه الزرقاء فهنا اعتقد
ان هيكون في شكل مشابه وفي النهايه هنوصل
ان كل الناس يبقوا والواجهه الاجتماعيه ما
لهاش اي
كل الروس سوا يعني
هذه قصه
مثلا لو وصلنا مثلا لو رجعنا للانستقرام
تحديدا يمكن لانه الانستجرام اعرف كثير
ناس فاتحين عليه حسابات اللي هي بزنس
وبيشتغلوا منها بزنس واشتغلوا صراحه فترات
طويله الى ان حصلوا على علامه توثيق من
انستغرام اللي هو يعد من اصعب منصات اللي
تحصل فيها على التوثيق طيب الان لما صار
الموضوع بفلوس انت يعني ما عاد في هدول
ضريتهم الانفلونسرز اللي عندك او اصحاب
الحسابات هذولي ما اعتقدش ان في ضرر لهم
فعلي لان القيمه الحقيقيه هي للمحتوى اللي
بيقدموه فلو هم بيقدموا محتوى قوي وعندهم
تفاعل عندهم جمهور وهكذا ان يكون في غيرهم
موثقين ما اعتقدش انها حتى هتسبب اي ضرر
مثلا او اللي عندهم يعني كان اول انه هم
الموثقين تعرف عارف عارف
بس الضهر الحقيقي
ولكن ممكن تدي للناس ثانيه فرصه ان هم
يظهروا ناس تانيه فرصه ان هم يقدروا
موهبتهم يوري منتجاتهم
غاضبه جدا من هذا الموضوع بتقول بس كفايه
جسيم ندفع في كل مكان مش رح ندفع لكم لا
يا متى ولا يا تويتر قديش هالكلام واقعي
للاسف هيدفعه
من الاخر
ندفع مش مشكله في الاخر اكونت ماشي لوحده
كده من غير علامه توثيق الناس هتبقى
بتبصله
كل الناس
بنشوف اشياء عجيبه هنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا في الاستوديو المختص في
التقنيه كريم فريد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]